this video is brought to you by
squarespace whether it's your new
profession or just a lifelong passion
start your journey to website glory with
squarespace check out their amazing
all-in-one platform through the link in
the description below
more about them in just a bit
we travel back to egypt in the 2700 bc
bish the first two dynasties of pharaohs
got this ancient civilization through
growing pains known as the early
domestic period which saw the
unification of the two lands of egypt
through war the innovation of the
hieroglyphic writing system and the
emergence of memphis as the new seat of
power now was time to make way for the
old kingdom a new era that marked the
beginning of egypt's first golden age
and some would argue the best of the
bunch it started with the third dynasty
a seven decade period that saw the
emergence of many of the elements which
made egypt unique and still fascinate us
today almost five thousand years later
the culture the unique art style the
pantheon of gods and of course the
eternal pyramids they come from the old
kingdom
in a somewhat unusual move we're
starting out with the main event as it
were because jose was undoubtedly the
most significant pharaoh of the third
dynasty so what made him so important
well that's easy his pyramid at sakhara
the necropolis outside the ancient
capital of memphis it was the first
pyramid of egypt in fact it's still the
oldest surviving pyramid in the world
joseph began his reign sometime around
the early 2600s bc succeed in kaiser
kenwi the final ruler of the second
dynasty the circumstances are a little
murky but the likeliest scenario was
that jose was his son with queen consort
nimathap now you might be wondering why
her father and son would be classified
in separate dynasties and you can blame
anetho for that one if that name sounds
vaguely familiar that's because we
mentioned him in most of our other
videos on ancient egypt he was a priest
and historian from the 3rd century bc
who wrote the age of tiaka possibly as
an egyptian counterpart to herodotus and
his chronicles although it has not
survived in its entirety the egyptia was
a history of egypt that included a
chronological rundown of all the
pharaohs up until that point which he
grouped into 30 dynasties modern
historians realized they needed some
classification system for all of these
dusty mummified pharaohs so they adopted
beneath those divisions since he'd
already done all the hard work even if
some dividing lines between dynasties
seem just a little bit random starting
with jose is the most commonly accepted
version but truth be told we are
stumbling around in the dark a bit by
that we mean that jose might not have
been the first pharaoh after all
according to some scholars there are
several surviving artifacts such as the
abardos king list the sikhara tablet and
the turin king list that egyptologists
rely on to establish the timeline of the
pharaohs they all name the rulers in
chronological order and literally
no two are the same sometimes the order
is different sometimes the names are
different some mention five pharaohs in
the third dynasty others only four it's
all a big jumble that egyptologists have
been trying to untangle for centuries
but there are still gaps wide enough
that you could park an affordable
family-sized sedan in them especially
when talking about the earliest
dynasties now it seems joser inherited
quite a wealthy and thriving kingdom he
was able to enact multiple ambitious and
expensive projects during his reign
which lasted between two and three
decades we have limited info on his
military career but it seems that his
main concern was to strengthen egypt's
borders although he didn't shy away from
the occasional scuffle with his
neighbors during his reign jose expanded
his borders both to the east into the
sinai region and to the west into libya
securing egypt's position as a dominant
regional force during its early history
one historian said that joseph's time as
pharaoh was defined by the construction
of architectural monuments agricultural
developments trade and the rise of
cities his greatest passion was to build
stuff and we're not just talking about
his pyramid joseph constructed many
temples including one that stopped a
deadly famine that was withering away
his entire kingdom this story has
survived through the ages thanks to the
appropriately named famine stella a
inscription found on sahel island near
the city of aswan once the main southern
frontier of egypt sure it was made
during the ptolemaic dynasty which was
2500 years after jose but well let's go
with it anyway according to the stellar
a severe drought caused seven years of
famine in egypt during jose's reign
children cried youngsters fell the
hearts of the old were grieving
courtiers were needy temples were shut
shrines covered with dust everyone was
in distress some could only crumple to
the ground in desperate prayer while
others resorted to theft and murder in
order to get their hands on what little
food was left meanwhile the pharaoh
could only watch helplessly as his
people withered away and died then one
night joseph had a haunting dream where
he received a visit from knum the god of
fertility credited with the creation of
the nile knum revealed to the pharaoh
that the famine was punishment for the
people of egypt for giving him the cold
shoulder and allowing his temple on the
island of elephantine to fall into
disrepair joseph vowed to correct this
injustice so he sailed to the island
himself he didn't just spruce up the old
temple with a shiny coat of paint
instead he built a brand new temple
bigger and better than ever happy with
his new place of worship kunum ended the
famine and joseph was hailed as the
savior of his people some of you might
be raising an eyebrow thinking that this
is clearly a legend and you're probably
right however it serves as a good
indication of joseph's reputation among
the ancient egyptians since even
thousands of years after his death he
was still regarded as a hero but now we
arrive at the highlight of his reign his
pyramid during the first two dynasties
pharaohs were buried in mastabas which
were rectangular tombs dug into the
ground with sloping walls and a flat
roof even though some of them were
pretty big with enough room to bury the
pharaoh and hundreds of his servants
they lacked the complexity and ambition
that we associate with the final resting
place of the pharaohs most importantly
they were made from mud bricks and wood
so they didn't last very long sure every
now and then the occasional limestone
was used but this was very much the
exception rather than the rule but then
when it was time to begin work on jose's
tomb his advisor imhotep had a light
bulb moment why don't we make it all out
of stone the pharaoh liked this idea so
he named imhotep his chief architect and
put him in charge of building his tomb
imote being the clever guy that he was
had another idea what if we put another
slightly smaller mustaber on top of the
first one and then another even smaller
one on top of that one and then another
one i'll tell that one six years later
we had the first egyptian pyramid and
probably the first large-scale monument
in history made entirely of stone
standing over 200 feet high it was the
tallest structure of its time the
complex which surrounded it also
included a mortary temple several courts
a large trench and a thick wall with a
long colonnade that connected the
entrance to the complex to the interior
structures suffice to say ancient
egyptians had never seen something on
this scale before and they were left
completely in awe they liked it so much
in fact that they had started worshiping
in hote and a couple of thousand years
later he was fully deified as the god of
medicine equated to the greek god
asclepius ultimately joseph's step
pyramid was overshadowed by the stature
and resplendence of the pyramids of giza
but his reign was undoubtedly a landmark
moment in history as are the structures
that came to define their civilization
now we'll get back to today's video in
just a second but first a quick word
from today's sponsor squarespace it's
the age of creation think about it
everyone is out there on the internet
making something blogs websites online
stores youtube channels you've either
got a great idea yourself or you
probably know someone who does and when
it's time to get that idea onto the
screen in front of you well if you need
a website that's where squarespace comes
in it's the perfect web tool to help you
fashion the internet into whatever you
want it to be maybe the sort of hands-on
type with lots of opinions and ideas
about what exactly your website should
look like if so very cool squarespace
gives you all of the customization
options you could ever want with no
updates no patches no technical bs to
worry about or maybe you just need
something functional something that
works with minimal thoughts so you can
focus on the content and not just the
code of paint just use one of their
quick beautiful templates to make a
website that's fresh and simple and
looks like it was made just for you and
once you're done setting up your website
locking in your name maybe playing with
some of the colors if you're so inclined
there are a ton of extra features so
that your site can thrive email
campaigns patronage portals social
integrations member only areas analytics
commercial options three people having
customer support everything you need in
one place so when you're ready to get
started on the next project of yours big
or small if it involves a website it's
got to be with squarespace you go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain
and let's get back into it
[Music]
of course the problem when you start at
the top is that there is nowhere to go
but down joseph's successor didn't
really live up to the high bar set at
the start of his dynasty his name was
sahemket sometimes also jose tereti and
we guess that he was joseph's son or
perhaps his younger brother so kemket is
so obscure he's one of those pharaohs
who is basically just a name inscribed
on an ancient wall and the main reason
why he failed to make a long-lasting
impact was his short reign going by the
various king lists he only ruled as
pharaoh for six or seven years but he
did leave one thing behind which is
worth talking about his unfinished
pyramid clearly jose's fancy new tomb
was a big hit and the pharaohs who came
after him tried to follow in his
footsteps so kem ket started
construction on his own pyramid right
next to that of jose in the necropolis
of sakhara but he didn't want his
pyramid to be just like joseph no no no
no that wouldn't be good enough he
wanted it to be bigger because when it
comes to pyramids bigger is always
better according to inscriptions it was
imhotep again who designed it so
unsurprisingly the construction was
similar however because sekhemket
reigned just for a few years only the
base was completed by the time of his
death if finished sekemge's pyramid
would have been around 230 feet tall
almost 30 feet taller than jose's
pyramid but since only the bottom layer
was constructed sakamget's pyramid was
basically just a fancier mastaba made
out of limestone instead of mud bricks
unsurprisingly his successor felt no
obligation to complete it so the
unfinished structure was quickly
engulfed by the desert sands and wasn't
even discovered until the 1950s speaking
of successes we arrive now at the most
contentious part the elusive third
pharaoh of the third dynasty generally
we know him by the name synacts though
he sometimes is identified as nebucha so
far this isn't so confusing or
controversial since pharaoh's had
multiple names but we also have some
inscriptions that identify nebker as the
first pharaoh of the dynasty instead of
jose so is it possible that synacte aka
nebca could have been the founder of the
third dynasty as we said most historians
say no but we could pour a little
gasoline onto this controversial fire by
pointing out that sanak was the only
pharaoh of the third dynasty not to
build a pyramid for himself or at least
try to like semket instead he opted to
be buried in a traditional mastaba which
would be more likely if he predated jose
and his step pyramid that's about all we
know about synact except for the recent
news that he may have been a giant this
little tip it comes to us courtesy of
scientists who analyze the skeletal
remains we think may have belonged to
some act while we cannot tell you for
certain that they are his bones we can
say that they belong to a very tall man
he stood six feet one inch tall at a
time when the average man was almost a
whole foot shorter medical experts who
inspected the bones believed that his
extraordinary height was caused by
gigantism which would make senect the
first diagnosed case in medical records
already we're in the final stretch for
the third dynasty in surprise surprise
we arrive at another pharaoh who was a
shadowy figure known mainly as a name
inscribed on a few walls and a few bowls
carver like sikkemcat it seems that
kaaba had a short reign of around six
years but unlike secamkett there is some
evidence not a lot but it's there that
the ancient egyptians might not have
been big fans of kaaba they tried to
erase his name from a few places and as
we know by now this practice of damnatio
memoria or condemnation of memory was
reserved only for the naughtiest rulers
the ones who cut up two shenanigans that
the people really didn't like such as
trying to abolish all of the old gods
and institute a new monotheistic
religion we're looking at you akhenaten
when you also take into account that
kaaba had a short reign it could suggest
that whatever he did may have angered
the egyptians enough to overthrow him
also like cecamket kaaba left behind an
unfinished pyramid although for reasons
known only to him he didn't consider
sakara a suitable place for his tomb
maybe he simply didn't want to be
overshadowed by jokes or maybe this was
part of whatever he did to ruffle
everyone's feathers but kaaba selected a
new spot for his eternal slumber at
zawayet el ion necropolis across the
nile from memphis their construction
began on a new step pyramid using almost
the same architecture as cecamked's
unfinished pyramid today the structure
is known simply as the layer pyramid and
it lies in ruins with only the base till
standing today scholars still can't
decide whether the pyramid was ever
finished or not some believe that work
on it was simply abandoned once carber
died others think that the pyramid was
completed and later torn apart so that
the stone could be reused in other
projects both scenarios suggest a
pharaoh who was not very popular with
the people
and so we reached the end of the line
for the third dynasty if until this
point the order of the pharaohs has been
a best guess scenario we're fairly
certain who the last ruler was hoony
possibly also known as quaharjet he is
mentioned several times as the immediate
predecessor of sneferu the first pharaoh
of the fourth dynasty and he may have
been his father as we saw earlier it
doesn't really make sense to group huni
and his son into different dynasties but
we just do as manetho commands
apparently he even gives nice symmetry
in relation to jose as we begin and in
the third dynasty with its most prolific
pyramid builder while jose was a pioneer
and innovator who clearly had the most
majestic pyramid in his era it seems
that huni was a quantity over quality
kind of guy also like jose he had a long
reign around two and a half decades that
allowed him to dedicate himself to
multiple construction projects honey
broke from tradition and built multiple
smaller step pyramids all over egypt
instead of one big one at zakara however
none of them were exactly show stealers
and today they mainly lion ruins they
puzzle historians as to their true
purpose pyramids were built to serve as
royal tombs but since none of them fit
the bill huni's true motivation for them
remains a mystery unfortunately for
honey modern scholars have stripped him
of his greatest achievement the maiden
pyramid possibly the most bizarre
structure in ancient egypt the maiden
pyramid was a hybrid it started out as a
step pyramid but then someone thought
that it would look better with smooth
angled sides it was encased in a
limestone outer layer and turned into a
true pyramid perhaps even the first true
pyramid in egypt's history however
because it was a prototype there were
still some bugs to work out so the outer
layer partially collapsed it was a
valuable learning experience for the
egyptians as they perfected their
pyramid building techniques in the
centuries that followed and today we're
left with a strange sight half the step
pyramid core exposed the other half
encased in limestone the maiden pyramid
was a grand ambitious project not just
due to the innovative and complex design
but also in its size in its finished
state it would have stood at an imposing
height of 300 feet almost 100 feet
taller than jose's pyramid it completely
dwarfed anything that came before it so
obviously honey would have earned some
serious bragging rights if he was the
one responsible for it for a while
egyptologists generally credited him
with the colossal structure they didn't
find his name inscribed anywhere inside
the pyramid but they found it on a few
artifacts and some nearby moustabas that
plus the long reign and the lack of
other suitable candidates all seemed to
suggest that huni was the likeliest
culprit alas scholarly consensus has
moved away and today people usually
credit his successor sneferu as the man
behind the maiden pyramid even so some
still think that credit should be shared
and see it as perhaps a father-son
project where honey built the original
step pyramid as deferred decided to add
the smooth outer layer it is feasible
although it doesn't explain why oni was
never buried there and why his name
doesn't appear on any inscriptions
inside it there is the possibility that
sneferu wanted all the glory for himself
and removed all mentions of his
predecessor's efforts but it seems
unlikely the mortary cult dedicated
honey survived for centuries after his
death indicating that he remained a
popular pharaoh among the egyptians and
speaking of his death it ended the
70-year period known as the third
dynasty and ushered in the fourth
dynasty the true age of the pyramids
this new era saw the construction of
ancient marvels unlike any that have
come before or after the marbles that
still stand today which is not something
that could be said about a lot of the
other monuments from that time however
none of that might have been possible
without the efforts and ambition of
pharaohs like jose or huni the vision
and creativity of men like imhotep the
third dynasty walked so the fourth one
could run
and we'll get to that fourth one soon no
doubt but for now i do hope you enjoyed
today's video if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and thank you for watching